hi I'm Chris Peach I'm a professor of
computer science at Stanford University
today I'll be answering questions from
Twitter this is coding support
[Music]
first up from mojem txt how many coding
languages are there well mojom there's a
lot of coding languages some of the most
popular ones include python that's great
if you're doing data science or if
you're writing scripts for your computer
there's JavaScript that's great if
you're writing a website and there's a
whole bunch of other ones like C C plus
plus Java and that's just five of the
top most common ones my friend from
University even made a coding language
of their own just for fun Eugene Daniel
asks can coding be self-taught
absolutely coding is such a special
field what matters is that you have the
skills it doesn't matter so much if you
have a credential saying you can do it
what matters is that you can pick up a
computer and you can code it and make it
do wonderful things there's a lot of
incredible resources out there Stanford
myself we offer free programming class
if you're interested I know a lot of
self-taught success stories when I
worked at Pixar I knew a lot of
programmers there who had never even
studied computer science in University
or anything like that they just taught
themselves and now we're working at one
of the coolest programming companies
okay next up glacial icon I always
wonder
apocalyptic and action movies how do
coders manage to save the day without
ever using stack Overflow and the
glacial icon I'm going to say that's a
fantastic question realistically when
we're coding we're using stack overflow
stack Overflow is a website where you
can go ask questions and see answers and
you can see code Snippets that other
people use to solve problems every
serious coder I know uses stack Overflow
to build better answers and so it's
pretty unrealistic that in an action
movie they're not using stack Overflow
so I guess if you only have a few
minutes to save the world maybe you have
to code without getting any help the
origin of the term stack Overflow is
actually an interesting story it comes
from one of the problems that you could
have while programming your program has
a certain amount of memory part of it's
called the stack and if that stack uses
too much memory it throws a stack
Overflow error and this often happens
when there's something going really
wrong with your program it's just
consuming memory wildly but the stack
Overflow website isn't just about that
problem it's a whole Community where
people come together and help each other
and I love that community of all of us
coming together and making each other
better R40 aha 40 asks what does front
and and back end mean I love this
question and you know what to show you
I'd like to explain a little bit of how
how the internet works when you use a
mobile application let's say you're
using Google Maps and Google Maps is
telling you how to get from point A to
point B there's a computer program
that's running on your phone and that's
called the front end but not all the
work is done on your phone in fact a lot
of the work might be done on a different
computer so what your phone does is it
connects over the internet to another
computer that we call a server and that
computer can do calculations and send
the answer back to your phone and you
know this is basically the idea of the
internet we have all these devices and
they're talking to other computers on
different parts of the world and
programs that run on this computer we
call those the back end so you have the
front end running on things that you
interface with and back end running on
things that are doing some work behind
the scenes that you'd never see you know
maybe it's a little bit like a car the
front end might be the steering wheel
that's what humans interact with there's
a whole bunch of Technology there the
back end is the technology you don't see
maybe it's like the engine it's doing
really important stuff but when
everything's working smoothly you just
interact with that steering wheel some
people only specialize in writing
programs for the front end some people
only specialize in writing programs for
the back end or you might hear this term
full stack engineer and those are
programmers who can do both the front
and and the back end and that's a good
thing to be next question from begus
Gasper what is the shortest piece of
code that changed the world that's a
good question and over a drink we could
have a great conversation and debate
this I'm gonna say back propagation for
artificial intelligence back propagation
is the few lines of code that tells an
artificial intelligence algorithm if I
see data how can I become smarter based
off of that data it's a very simple
piece of code based off some cool
calculus and that's where most AI gets
its intelligence from say your AI
algorithm is trying to learn what a cat
is and it sees a picture of a cat it can
put it through its own little AI brain
back propagation will tell it how to
change its AI brain so that it is better
able to understand cats in the future
pseudo arba doesn't really have a
question but a cute little rhyme how
much could a C plus plus if a c plus
could plus plus C plus plus is one of
the most popular programming languages
in fact it's the one that I first
learned on that's how old I am and C
plus plus it's what you want to use if
you're writing a really intense program
like a 3D computer game or if you're
writing the program to animate a Pixar
movie C plus plus is what you'd use C
plus plus is actually descendant of
another programming language called C
and C is like the grandfather of all
languages like the Latin equivalent from
which many different languages attend C
plus plus is one of those and you can
see where he got its name from it's C
and then plus plus is programming speech
for one better so it's like I'm like C
but I'm a little bit better and there's
other descendants you might have heard
of like Java and Python and the fact
that all these three languages descend
from C tells you how similar that they
they are to one another why is C or C
plus plus so good for video game
programming because it's so
computationally intense you have to to
render an entire 3D World with trees in
the distance and things animating in the
front and that just asks so much of your
computer C and C plus plus they're like
your bare bones programming languages
they're the most efficient so they can
run the fastest and they can do the most
computations per second Python and Java
they're easier to read so it's easier to
write the program but the computer can't
run them as quickly Los merenges 14 asks
my computer science teacher asked what
is Python and I replied a very dangerous
snake uh and he beat me up I feel like
we have to have a different conversation
about corporal punishment here did you
know the name python the name for this
programming language actually comes from
Monty Python's Flying Circus the person
who invented the programming language
called python was a big fan of the TV
show so gave it that name it's a general
pro purpose programming language so you
could write a Google Maps backend on it
you could write data science you could
just write a script that does something
fun or you could write a chat bot even
do you want to see what python looks
like I can show you a really basic intro
to play Python program uh hello world
and print 10 numbers
here's an example of a very simple
Python program this says when you run
this program so somebody goes to the
computer and they click on click on your
program it's going to open up a console
and it's going to say hello world that's
the greeting we use when we're trying to
show that we can write our first program
it's like your program saying hi I'm new
to this world tell me all about it and
then your program
in very cool faction says I'm going to
print the numbers the first 10 numbers
so it'll print zero then one then two
then three then four then five then six
and seven then eight the nine main is
what happens when somebody starts your
program so deaf main says when someone
starts your program I'm going to execute
all of these commands and then I write
the commands uh one by one the first
command I wrote is print hello world
print doesn't mean like print through
your printer it means show up on the
screen the next line says for I in range
one of the great things about computer
is that they can do lots of repetitive
tasks without beingcoming frustrated
humans not so much this is one of those
basic commands you need to know to make
a computer repeated task it says I want
to repeat something 10 times and 10
times I would like to print out a value
this is a value that's going to change
numbers from 0 up to nine so when you
run this program it'll print zero then
one then two then three and four then
five then six and seven and eight the
nine next question from Che Esquire what
is the meaning of pair 404 Arrow 404 is
what you see when you go to a website
and that website doesn't exist and the
web page is saying I don't know what
website you're looking for more broadly
when programs don't know what to do or
when they break they often throw a thing
called an error and as a human you're
given these errors errors always have
codes they tell the human and they tell
somebody who's trying to diagnose what
went wrong exactly what the problem was
so when you see Arrow 404 that's a
specific message saying exactly what
went wrong was that I wasn't able to
find the particular URL you were looking
for web error codes were actually
defined by the guy who invented the web
Tim Bern early as I understand it he was
just coming up with sequential codes I
think the first four means that there is
a problem with your web page 401 402 403
404 or just different problems that
could come up when you're trying to load
a web page okay next question formula
are programming coding the same thing
yes coding is the process of opening up
an application on your computer and
writing a sequence of commands that look
a lot like English but are in a specific
language that your computer can
understand you can code in something
like python or JavaScript these are the
languages of coding and that's how you
tell a computer I want you to perform
all these actions when somebody hits a
button or when somebody opens this
application programming is the exact
same thing you're making a program when
you're coding future leer what is
Raspberry Pi and what can be used for
futurelear this is a Raspberry Pi and
this is one of the world's cheapest
computers what are we looking at here
we're looking at small version of a
motherboard and on it it has things that
you can plug in like a USB has a place
for audio and a place for internet
connection and on the chip it has a
thing called a CPU so it's Central
Processing Unit so it can process
programs and it has some space for
memory so it can store some data it can
connect to a power source it could
connect to a monitor and it can connect
to lots of sensors and why is it so cool
let's say you want to write a program
but you wanted to make get physical and
interact in the real world maybe you
wanted to make a robot or maybe you
wanted to make a smart doorbell or
something like that you could use this
super cheap programmable computer and
maybe you put a sensor in it and maybe
you make you know another actuator and
then you make something happen in the
real world next question from TJ Jesse
TJ how do you code AI wow what a deep
deep question in so few words people
might be wondering what AI means AI
stands for artificial intelligence and
artificial intelligence is a very broad
term it literally means any algorithm
which is acting in an intelligent way
the most common type of artificial
intelligence is a type called machine
learning and that's when an algorithm
gets smarter when it looks at data or
when it gets experiences of its own the
most common way to code AI is in Python
using something like Pi torch or
tensorflow you say here is the structure
of my artificial intelligence Network
and once I have that structure I'm going
to write some code that can take in data
and I'll tell my artificial intelligence
to get smarter using data and that's all
done in Python but in 2022 the way
people write AI could be changing there
are these really large artificial
intelligence networks which have been
published and sometimes writing AI is
figuring out how to talk to these really
billion parameter neural networks so you
can put in prompts that would give you
interesting answers
do you practice algorithms frequently if
yes why I do practice algorithms
frequently I practice algorithms
frequently for lots of reasons one
because they're neat one because I teach
them one because they keep me becoming a
great programmer but also because we
invent algorithms but what's an
algorithm an algorithm is basically any
piece of code that does an interesting
task so maybe it solves a problem that
would take a lot of thought one example
of something we worked on recently is we
made an algorithm that can do a digital
eye test and it's always being
thoughtful about what size letter to
show somebody next one algorithm you
might hear a lot about is like The Tick
Tock algorithm what that does is it
decides what video you should see next
how does it it work that's in fact a bit
of a mystery I don't think they tell the
world this is how our algorithm works
but when people say The Tick Tock
algorithm what they're talking about is
how Tick Tock chooses that next video
and um ass git Hub what the hell is
GitHub it sounds rude GitHub is not rude
hub's your friend GitHub is a website
where a lot of US host our code so when
I write a program often I'm working with
other people and we use GitHub to store
our code a lot like using Google docs
for when you're working on a Word
document together github's our place for
code it's also a place where you can go
and see other people's code some people
choose to put their code up publicly
which means that when I'm working on a
project I can see what other people have
done that's one of the cool things about
computer science we're always building
on top of each other's ideas so if
somebody's built a really cool program I
don't have to start from scratch off and
I can build a top of their really cool
program next up from Nana Simon which
coding language is the easiest one
that's a good question when we teach
intro computer science at Stanford we
use Python because we think it's the
most gentle introduction to programming
but in the very first week we use an
even simpler programming language called
Carol this is Carol Carol's a simple
robot Carol can only move turn left put
down a beeper or pick up a beeper but
when you add in some of the basic
control flow of programming Carol can do
anything that we can do in Python which
is incredible we use as a gentle
introduction just to show you the basics
and it's a great way to learn if you're
curious diners asks do you have to be
good at math to code I low-key want to
learn bomb terrible at math do it learn
to code you don't need to be great at
math to code this is a common
misconception I think it has its
historical roots in the fact that when
programming was first invented they
didn't know where to put it inside the
university and they happened to put it
in the math department so people think
you have to be great at math but in
reality I've seen so many amazing
programmers who don't feel that
confident in math and you know what
learn to program it'll probably help
your math out because it helps you do
lots of things that use logic and math
is one example of something that could
use some logic I'd say what skills do
you really want to have if you want to
learn how to program the desire to build
things because programming is all about
making stuff and patience because
sometimes when you're making things it
won't work out the way you expected and
if you're patient you're willing to work
through step by step you'll figure it
out
bangkash1401 I have always been curious
about the origin of coding computer
software artificial intelligence my
questions were like how scientists could
have bridged hardware and software for
the first time what was there mean to do
that and when did they realize that such
a thing could be possible oh the history
is so interesting in it it plays into so
many important parts of human history
certainly one of the turning points was
World War II When Alan turning and a
group of other people in the UK came up
with what some people would consider the
first computer why so that they could
decrypt German messages that they were
sending between each other and you
needed to try a whole bunch of different
secret keys if you want to decrypt it
they built what I would consider some of
one of the first computers and would try
lots and lots of different keys until it
could decrypt the German messages you
could think of this as one of the first
pieces of artificial intelligence
because cracking someone else's code
that sounds a lot like intelligence but
the history of software goes way before
that people were theorizing that you
could have something like a computer
back back in the day in the 1800s at a
Lovelace and another professor Charles
Babbage they were saying I think we
could have computers that work on
digital ones and zeros and actually
these things could solve problems and
add a Lovelace without even having a
computer started writing all these
different algorithms and programs when
computers didn't even exist and they
kind of showed the world this is going
to be cool once we have the electronics
for it nihar DM asks is coding required
for web design what's web design web
design is when you make a website and
that can often involve coding it turns
out a lot of the websites you interact
with they're running a lot of
interesting code underneath the hood
what happens when you click this button
when I fill in this form what's supposed
to occur next and people write that in a
coding having said that a big part of a
web design team is also artists people
are just thinking how can I make this a
beautiful website or how can I make this
a beautiful user experience and it's a
really valuable skill to learn how to
become that artist or that user
experience designer you don't
necessarily need coding for that pretty
hat hacker asks the real question is do
you need to know how to code in order to
hack why or why not we should break down
what hack means because it means
different things to different people to
some people hacking means breaking into
someone's website or something like that
maybe getting into a database stealing
some passwords in my field we actually
call that cracking and that's quite
illegal and I wouldn't recommend people
do that hacking in the world of computer
science sometimes is a shorthand for
writing really impressive code
regardless of which version you're doing
the illegal version or the less illegal
version if you want to be doing really
interesting things with computers that
maybe go against the grain certainly
knowing how to code is important don't
do anything illegal at home Jerry
bandito why is coding important coding
is how you get compared is to do things
for you so the ability to communicate
with computers is just such a powerful
tool to have whether you're not you're
doing data science or you're in policy
or you're in art no matter what you're
doing there's probably a time when your
career would benefit from being able to
speak the language of computers but I
also think coding isn't just useful it's
also beautiful it is a really beautiful
process of how you speak to the computer
how you create things out of nothing
when I'm coding I take ideas in my mind
and I make them into reality sometimes
that's useful and sometimes it's just a
beautiful process okay that's all the
questions hope you learned something
until next time
[Music]